what can I do to help make my viewers
life better you know that's really all
it boils down to just press record and
just start because you learn with each
video you just have to listen to your
viewers they will guide your journey as
a Creator most of the people who
subscribe to your channel subscribe to
your channel for what you have been
offering them and if you Veer off that a
lot you're going to disappoint them
is it possible to truly turn your
passion into a powerful YouTube channel
well I'm so excited for today's think
media podcast because we're talking to a
Creator who's generating over 1 million
views and is about to hit 1 million
subscribers on YouTube Mary from Mary's
Nest is the best-selling author of the
modern pioneer cookbook a former New
Yorker who's now living this simple life
with her sweet husband in the Texas Hill
Country and she's been a modern pioneer
in the kitchen for over 20 years but she
didn't start there she started from zero
like we all do sharing her passion and
has built a powerful Community has built
a powerful YouTube channel and is going
to be sharing tips and insights of how
she built the powerful really YouTube
Empire that she has today so Mary
welcome to the think media podcast hi
Sean and hired to your wonderful
audience thank you very much for having
me and thank you for that very kind uh
introduction well I'm so excited to have
you on and you know it's wild to be
talking to you in this moment because I
want to say right we go back five or six
years and you uh eventually join VRA
that's when you really were on my radar
but at the time it was you hadn't really
posted a video or you were just starting
to post you're just building your
confidence but you fast forward to today
and a traditional publisher reached out
to you and congrats on your your book
that's launching soon that's available
for pre-order you already have this over
play button you're gonna get a gold play
button probably this year and you have
you've been getting you get messages and
emails from people's lives being
impacted plus you know money's coming in
and so literally you're living this
YouTube Dream but it took years and I
think that's what's encouraging as we
get into these tactics but I want to
take it all the way back what made you
want to actually start YouTube In the
Beginning well really in the beginning I
had been teaching traditional cooking
just right here in my kitchen just to
friends and neighbors anybody who wanted
to learn I really feel very strongly
about keeping these Traditions alive and
my son was going off to college and he
and my husband said Gee you know you
really should put your cooking classes
on YouTube you're very passionate about
this and you can reach a much broader
audience and so I thought well that'll
be wonderful I'll you know I I watched
YouTube videos I mean I knew all about
YouTube but I had no idea how one made
videos
and so i s but I said well I'm just
gonna jump in and I'm gonna do this and
this will be wonderful I you know you
always hear with YouTube you can reach
people all over the world and I said how
great is that and so I typed into you
into the community you know into YouTube
how do you make YouTube videos and you
came up along with some other people and
I just you know went through watched
your video watched a few other people's
videos but I said to myself boy this
Sean Connell he's great he speaks my
language because you're very basic you
break it down it's not complicated you
don't feel overwhelmed that oh I can't
do this some of the other people who
teach this on YouTube and nothing
against them but it's a little more they
sometimes make it a little more
complicated and it's a little difficult
to understand but I liked you at a video
okay this is a cheap camera you know
and uh then in watching your videos as I
learned that you had the course the
video ranking Academy and so my husband
got home from work and I said I think I
need to take this man's course because I
need to learn how to how to do this and
do it and I also was thinking you know
I'm a realistic person I recognize the
fact that there's you know expense
associated with all of this and so I
said okay I need to approach this as a
business I want to do everything I can
for my viewers and give them a wonderful
experience and always have them at the
Forefront and teach them and so on and
so forth and be serious about this and
try also to create a business that would
create income to offset the costs of the
various things that come up because in
learning from you you know it becomes a
lot more than just YouTube you know I
started a website and an email list and
I use WP engine for my website because I
wanted to make the experience for my
viewers really nice and fast but uh the
the more you grow the more you have to
upgrade
so uh it was it was just a wonderful
combination of things that you offered
in your video ranking Academy how to do
this as a business and but at the same
time how to make the best experience for
the viewer and at the same time how to
make it easier for me to understand and
you know I often say if I can do this I
had no background in this if I can do
this and build this to the point it'll
be five years the end of July anybody
can do this but you just have to follow
your instructions you know I've I've
shared with you in the past that you
know sometimes we all you know we all
have our own little egos and we say oh
well I know what I want to do I know how
to do this and all and I always tell my
friends you know nothing yeah
Sean tells you to do
I I'm an example of that because you
know just being an older person and not
having a lot of experience with video
and social media and all of it it can be
very overwhelming but so that's how I I
got started and I took your class in
2017 launched my channel in 2018 after I
took your course so I knew what to do
and I just have always followed your
steps I mean I'm a little old-fashioned
you know I I know my titles are very
basic you know I'm not already like
clickbaitish or fancy you know I'm how
to do X but I learned from you about
keywords and all of that and my
thumbnails they may be a little
old-fashioned but I'm me you know I'm a
little old-fashioned and I think people
and as you've taught you know you have
to be yourself
don't try to be other people don't
compare you know so on and so forth you
can be inspired by other people but the
bottom line is you just have to do what
you do and be yourself and I really
learn that uh from taking your class and
so I just went along
and here we are almost five years later
and like you said I can't believe there
are so many people who want to join me
on this traditional foods Journey it's
fantastic so that was kind of a long
answer not amazing and and I want to go
back five years ago when you finally
posted the first video first of all what
did what was that what went into that
first video did you end up buying a
camera did you just use your phone did
you do any editing what was the first
few videos in terms of workflow what I
did is in the beginning I had a plan
that I would do I would make 15 videos
that was my initial goal well you know
you have to set goals for yourself and
you have to look at your life and you
have to say you know okay what you know
I have other responsibilities outside of
YouTube and so I had to look at
everything that was going on in my life
and what did I have time to do and I
said okay I want to do a series of and I
hoped I would be able to do more but you
know you just said chunks you set goals
and I said I want to make a series of 15
videos and I'm going to set aside time
in my week each week to pick a day or
two whatever was working for me at the
time and I'm going to film these 15
videos and I I know I didn't have a
camera and I didn't know
you know sometimes you have to give me a
little Grace because sometimes I there
were things I just didn't know I didn't
even focus on the fact that you could
use your phone you know this is so much
in the beginning was so new to me
so I searched on think media and you had
great videos on equipment and great
videos for people just getting started
and how to do this when it you know
making it very affordable
so I went to the camera shop I live
outside of Austin Texas and so I went to
a camera shop in Austin and uh this is
you know back when hey even we still get
the newspaper about well elephant but I
went through the newspaper they had a
big ad they were having a sale so I went
and I bought the camera that you
recommended it was a cannon and it was
on sale and I already had a tripod I had
a tripod and lights uh from projects
that my son would do that he just left
when he left and and left me a um
you know Mac computer and so we just set
up my husband was helping me you know I
would watch your videos and I just put
the camera on the tripod and I in my
kitchen island and it was just me and
the camera my husband was like in
another room
uh I did make one good investment and it
did take me a little while to figure out
how to use it and some of my earlier
videos or the sound is not always great
but I did make the investment in the
Sennheiser I think if I'm pronouncing it
correctly the microphone because that
was something that I had also learned
you know in watching your videos that
people will forgive if the video is not
perfect and they'll forgive if you're
not perfect but if people can't hear you
they'll click out so I did make that
investment so we set everything up I
went behind my kitchen island and I
showed people how to roast a chicken
[Laughter]
and I it was a very interesting
experience
um in terms of the workflow because
there was a lot of stop and start uh I
it was a little funny because I would be
silly but just to make the editing
process easier and I'll share this maybe
this will help some of your viewers who
are new to making videos I would
literally say I would realize I I was
finished with saying something and I
wasn't ready to say the next thing but I
didn't want to like turn off the camera
and a big rigmarole and I would just say
cut
and when you go to edit then you're like
okay that's gonna be cut out and then
you know I would pick up with okay all
right now we're gonna move on to the
next segment you know and so it made
editing a little easier but that uh so
that was just the workflow and we just
filmed that doing the best that I could
I didn't have any overhead shots I
didn't have any close-up shots uh
we just did the best we could you know
my husband and I and uh little by little
you know we learned with each video
you're so right just press record and
just start because you learn with each
video okay I'm gonna need to and I never
had a second camera I eventually bought
a new camera I did upgrade but we would
just use the phone to take pictures of
what I was doing so people could have
that up close
and then we didn't know how to use the
phone to make a video that we could then
add to the other video which we do now
but we would just use the Ken Burns
option in Final Cut Pro you know and so
it would make it move yeah
and you
learn all these little techniques as you
go along and that was my workflow uh
just each week you know trying to do one
or two videos and my videos tend to be
long so when I yes I do try to batch
film but and I and I have right from the
beginning but it was always I was batch
filming you know like two if I was lucky
maybe three videos because sometimes
they're an hour long you know because
I'm teaching a class
so it was an interesting experience what
were some of the emotions so it's so
cool to hear about the technical side
you you worked with what you had you got
your son had some lighting in the
computer you went to the camera shop
just piece by piece put it together set
it all up put it in the kitchen put the
apron on press record
but as you thought about uploading some
of those first videos was there was
there any emotions that you can remember
feeling or any overwhelm or just did it
did it seem daunting was there any
encouragement that you have for the
emotions that hit us when it's like you
said you're learning an entirely new set
of skills that's quite a bit to take on
do you remember how you felt during that
time and some of the emotions you were
going through oh yes I had a lot of
emotions questions number one you're
very nervous in the beginning even
though I I'm a naturally outgoing person
but it's one thing to be outgoing with
your friends and family and people in
your community it's another to put
yourself out there in a in a environment
that you have no idea who's watching you
and then also too I had emotions you
know like well my friends will people in
my neighbor in my community think I'm
silly you know that that definitely was
one you know and people who might come
across it you know from my church and
they would be like do you like make a
video or something what are you doing
you know I felt a little embarrassed you
know initially and uh now it's like
they'll come up to be in the grocery
store and they'll be like oh I saw the
one on Stocking The Pantry okay let's
talk yeah but initially I I had that
emotion of I was a little worried like
would I feel embarrassed yeah in my
community that I was doing this and then
just the notion of all these people you
don't know who's watching your video and
you know what are they going to think of
you you know I think you have to be will
you have to have a little bit of a tough
skin and you have to be open to
constructive criticism and you have to
be able to deal with the negative
comments that come and you know that can
initially be a little hard but I I had
all of these emotions I also had the
emotion of impatience
and I was very impatient and I would get
frustrated at our lack of knowledge at
our lack of ability to edit a video and
now when I go back and I look at my
first or second or third video I'm proud
I say wow you know all things can
considered it's not so bad after all you
know and my sauerkraut video is one of
my earlier videos and that's the video
that led me to being able to write the
modern pioneer cookbook so you never
know you never know you know so I I want
people to know that hit record start
recording and you never know one of
those earlier videos really may be
something that does well that had a
couple of hundred views when I first put
it out and but I had what maybe 50
subscribers and I was like oh okay
that's great that video has over 2
million views today you know so you
never you just never know but yes that
the the feeling is that you might be
embarrassed the feelings that are you
good enough you know you it's very I
think so many of us experience that and
I've heard this term uh which is a term
I didn't wasn't familiar with prior to
YouTube but in YouTube but imposter
syndrome and you know I did feel that I
was like all right you know I've taught
this in my kitchen but you know who who
am I you know to be teaching all these
people that I think that I want to teach
on YouTube you know am I good enough you
know can I really teach this you know uh
and make a video out of it and will
people benefit from it will it be
helpful to people you know I had all
these emotions running through my mind
and I think and and also you know can I
handle criticism and can I be patient
can I look at this as for the Long Haul
can I be can I just calm down and
realize that videos on how to make bone
broth or sauerkraut from someone like me
you're not gonna go viral you know and
and I it's gonna be slow you know going
getting your subscribers and getting
your views and are you gonna be okay
with that you know and initially you
think oh okay great I'm gonna get a lot
of subscribers right away you know and
then he's like oh okay I got to be a
little patient and I gotta put the work
in and I've got to just keep keep seeing
this as the Long Haul but the good news
is all of those emotions that you
initially feel over time get tamped down
and you calm down and you feel better
about yourself because you're making the
videos you have to
like you say press record you have to
make the videos and you have to set up
the schedule for yourself so that you're
not running hot and cold you have to say
Okay I'm going to look at my life what
can I do I have this I have that
whatever the case may be wherever you
are in your life you know the
responsibilities that you have and so
you have to say to yourself okay I can
put out one video a month or I can put
out one video every other week or once a
week and I set the schedule for myself
at the time that I was going to do two
videos a week Wednesday and Saturday
most of the time now I just do Saturday
if I have extra time I'll add in
Wednesday uh but I I found that
initially Wednesday and Saturday it I I
saw it as a long haul and I recognize
that sometimes two videos a week was too
much for me and if I'm going to be in
this for the Long Haul okay I'm at least
gonna do one video a week and then
taking some time off around Holly days
but always coming back always long haul
you know on the journey and with those
emotions the more videos you make the
easier it is to uh feel better about
yourself and be able to be more in
control of your emotions man there's so
many powerful insights there I think one
that you know for everybody listening to
this you're not alone
I think everybody can relate to what
you're saying but sometimes we think it
that dialogue in our own head is just
something we're going through when no
it's it's every YouTube Creator it's
every entrepreneur that takes the leap
of faith and the step of courage to
press record start uploading and to
frankly just choose to fight those
emotions because they're there they're
real it's like feeling fear and courage
isn't the absence of fear it's moving
forward despite feeling fear
it's also inspiring to hear what's
waiting for you on the other side of
getting out of your comfort zone your
sauerkraut video two million views and
you mentioned even patience I mean you
probably didn't imagine when you first
posted it because it wasn't viral in the
sense of it took two days to go to two
million it still gets views to today
that's the VRA dream it's our VRA system
to where okay wow if I make solid
Evergreen videos
if I'm patient then I can still be
getting views for years to come and so
man what is waiting for you listening to
the think media podcast on the other
side of choosing to acknowledge your
feelings and emotions but not let them
be
dictators of the action that you take I
did hear that quote once feelings and
emotions or indicators they're not
dictators you know if I feel afraid okay
why is that but it shouldn't dictate me
not taking action I acknowledge it I
respect that I'm gonna take action
anyways and I love that you said action
taking actually making the videos is the
answer to the emotion
um we can get so stuck in negative
thought patterns especially when we're
idle when all we have time to do is to
think about what we're not doing we get
in a procrastination Loop or something
and then we beat ourselves up and then
we think about it more like the it's
kind of interesting that the the
antidote is to get busy stop
overthinking and get busy just doing the
work and then momentum is built and it's
also encouraging to hear that over time
those voices get quieter and you get
more confident and we have you know one
of the things that we've been bundling
together with VRA is our camera
confidence course we talk about the
confidence competence Loop where
confidence grows as your competence
grows and it's like well which comes
first the chicken or the egg you're like
I don't know you just gotta start
because you post a video and then you're
like it wasn't that great but I'm a
little more confident now and then a
little more confident the next video is
a little bit better and then the skill
is good and it's a loop that goes
getting more skilled growing more
confidence getting more skilled growing
more confidence and uh man your journey
has just been so uh encouraging
what advice do you have for people when
they are just starting and a
conversation we had a while back one of
my favorite things that you mentioned
and you could think about a few other
tips to share with us you said you'll
get more views when you put the viewer
first what does that mean to you
definitely and uh from day one I it was
always about the viewer and you know I
make how-to videos and I I think that's
very important and I think it's
something that we have to accept about
ourselves that initially the viewers
don't know who we are and they're not
particularly interested necessarily in
who we are and that can maybe hurt your
feelings a little uh because you might
say I'm a nice person don't they want to
know about me and you know I think a lot
of people say oh I'm gonna do a vlog and
I'm gonna do this or whatever the case
may be and I've had this discussion with
other creators and we've all come to the
acceptance and the agreement that unless
you're some big celebrity
people are not particularly interested
in your life in hearing you just wax
poetic you know as they say a vlog on
about some particular subject that that
can be very difficult I think to have
success and I think when people try that
and then and the success doesn't come uh
for them they can be easily
disillusioned and then maybe stop making
videos whatever the case may be
uh because those videos don't always put
the viewer first it's not that people
can't Vlog but if they do it's going to
have to be offering some value to the
viewer I do think that if you're
starting out starting with how-to videos
can be easier because you're offering
some skill you're offering to teach
someone how to do something and when
that person is searching on YouTube for
how to do something you may come up and
I think that that's a very important
thing to always have in your mind
whenever you're making videos how does
this benefit someone how does this
benefit once you start to accumulate
subscribers and viewers how is this
really going to benefit my viewer how is
this going to make their life better
what do they feel they're going to take
away after they've watched my video is
yeah and all and so you always have to
be running this through your mind when
you start thinking of ideas of videos to
create and so and I think that's very
important and
um I can't remember if it was Nolan or
Omar on your team they did a video and
and this is what I love about think
media and video ranking Academy is the
simple things that you focus on that
creators can do that are very manageable
and I truly believe is what helps you
have success on YouTube
uh as I said it was one of those
gentlemen and they explained about
setting up your YouTube page your home
page and to make it look attractive to
someone who may watch one or two of your
videos and then may click on your little
picture to say Okay I want to know
what's this lady all about what's this
man all about and they come to your home
page make your home page welcoming to
the viewer have it say something what is
the viewer going to get you know I have
on my home page traditional cooking I
learned traditional cooking for the
modern pioneer in the kitchen you know
something to that effect it's always
you know it's funny I I feel that it's
always it's just always about putting
the viewer first and I think that that
can be hard for some people because
people can say oh I have this story to
tell or whatever the case may be that's
very nice but will it benefit your
viewer if if it's inspiring that might
be very beneficial I learned very early
on that if you lose sight of putting the
viewer first you it's very difficult to
have success on YouTube I think that
even people who are not doing how-to
videos like if you have some sort of
entertainment some sort of Comedy some
sort of music again we are all in a
sense entertainers we are entertaining
people either through how to or
something else but whatever you're doing
always say to yourself how is this going
to benefit my viewer this is not about
me I have to put myself on the back
burner this is about my viewer what can
I do to help my viewer what can I do to
help make my viewers life better you
know that's really all it boils down to
and you've done that so well I'm curious
you mentioned as you made your channel
attractive and you got clear these
traditional cooking for the modern
pioneer videos what is your feelings on
staying in your lane or staying
um in your niche and have you
experimented or have you been tempted
over the last few years to try different
other ideas or
videos that are separate or a little bit
off brand maybe from your core content
and what lessons have you learned in
those experiments I do think it's very
you know I I do have sort of strong
feelings about this I do think it's
important to stay in your Niche most of
the people who subscribe to your channel
subscribe to your channel for what you
have been offering them and if you Veer
off that a lot you're going to
disappoint them and they may unsubscribe
they may not but you're going to
disappoint them and again you're not
putting the viewer in in the Forefront
of your thought process your video
making process and you can experiment
within your Niche but it's good to
experiment and maybe broaden your
content
based on what your viewers or your
commenters are telling you you know like
I do well with traditional cooking but
even within my subscriber base and I
think this is why I do have a lot of
subscribers yet my videos none of them
go viral and they even will start slow
even to this day but they grow over time
and it's because my viewers will say to
me because I get this in comments and
emails all the time alrighty I just
finished your bone broth playlist it's
taken me six months but I'm making bone
broth now I'm coming back and I'm gonna
watch your fermentation videos yeah so
you may have you know these subscribers
and they're just coming to you for bone
broth and you've given them bone broth
but then they're on their traditional
foods journey and so then they're ready
to maybe try fermentation and or
sourdough bread whatever the case may be
so whatever video I put out I never feel
bad saying oh you know it's not I have a
lot of subscribers but I'm not getting
like a gazillion views but that's okay
because I know people all of my
subscribers my viewers are in different
places on their Journey okay that said
when you decide you want to try
something new you have to say to
yourself is this have I been getting
questions comments about this and I was
just teaching traditional cooking but
then during 2020 I was getting a lot of
requests wow I only had a week's worth
of food in my house how do I stock my
pantry and so and that's a very natural
offshoot of traditional cooking most
traditional Cooks have very well stocked
pantries so I started making videos
about that they did very well prior to
that
I and earlier on in my channel I had
some lovely friends and they were saying
oh let's do some videos together and
whatnot and and I really let them
lead that rather than they were other
creators leading it rather than allowing
my subscribers and my viewers to lead
the direction I would go into I think
when you let other creators Lead You
Lead your the content that you're making
through maybe a collaboration you can
get off track and you can get out of
your Niche and you can get people your
viewers upset with you I had some videos
where people were like oh let's do a
collab and as I've shared I've shared
this with you Sean previously uh your
your listeners may find this funny and
they said let's do a video on what we
got at the thrift shop and so I thought
well this is really not cooking but it's
not really to do with the kitchen but
maybe the things that I buy or whatever
will be of interest to people because
it's sort of in the traditional
old-fashioned lifestyle whatever OFA
seven sakes did that backfire
[Laughter]
and what you got at the thrift shop
thank you
[Laughter]
and I realized that I needed to be very
careful
about veering too much off my Niche and
I have to always be loyal to my viewers
to my subscribers why did they come to
me why are they coming to me what what
are they wanting to know they're wanting
to know how to make traditional food how
to create a no-waste kitchen how to
stock a pantry and use all of that food
efficiently how to be prepared in the
event that emergencies hit and you still
have to make traditional meals and so
it's all under this umbrella and I know
under that umbrella to stay basically
under that umbrella or to stay in that
lane and and not to Veer out of it now
it doesn't mean that you don't grow and
you don't uh have flexibility to be
creative and make new videos you just
have to listen to your viewers they will
guide your journey as a Creator they
will help you so that you don't get to
the point where you feel Lord with what
you're doing or and sometimes it breaks
my heart when I feel people say oh I
hate I can't do it anymore I hate it and
I I always say that's probably because
you're either trying to copy other
creators or you're not being you know
genuine to yourself you're not listening
to your viewers you're not reading your
comments and you're trying to do a keep
up with the Joneses of other creators
don't worry about what other creators
are doing worry about what your viewers
are telling you to do and you'll be fine
and staying stay in your lane and I know
people will disagree with me you know I
know that a lot of people say oh you
have to broaden your Niche and this that
and the other thing yes to a certain
extent that's true but broaden it based
on what your viewers are asking you for
because they came to you in the
beginning for a reason and they want to
stay with you for a reason and your
videos may prompt them to think of other
things questions whatever whatever and
you can expand upon that by but just
from my personal experience I found that
whenever I veered out of my Niche and
did something that was not more on point
with what my original vision for my
channel was things didn't go well and I
got negative comments and unsubscribes
and so on and so forth that is YouTube
gold and
just the idea of the pathway to kind of
broadening your Niche or perhaps going
in a slightly different direction or
wider direction is not because of
copying other creators it's not because
of listening just to people you're
collaborating with but being absolutely
obsessed with the people you're there to
serve and their insights and that's one
thing I want to encourage listeners
because you're at this place and
experiencing this as well eventually
when your YouTube channel hits a Tipping
Point of momentum
there becomes so much viewer feedback
that you could never run out of good
video ideas you can never run out of
powerful insights about what to create
next and you things that you wouldn't
conceive and things that even chat GPT
or some AI platform wouldn't necessarily
recommend to you there's just something
about listening and staying connected
and staying so close to the core
community
we always say never upload videos that
your subscribers didn't subscribe for
but if a brand but your subscribers are
telling you they want it then that
becomes the thread and it's not a forced
thread from some external following some
Trend it's from the internal core so I
don't know about you but I am super
inspired listening to Mary and her story
make sure you're subscribed and wherever
you listen to the think media podcast
rate review if you're on YouTube let me
know your feedback in the comments smash
the like button and I can't wait to
connect with you right here on the think
media podcast